[Music]
on this Wednesday night new charges
against the former officers involved in
the killing of George Floyd
we went justice for what's going on one
has a murder charge upgraded three other
fired officers are now charged to paused
since the pandemic the mission to get
Canada's military back in motion long
term solutions to long-term care the
changes home operators and unions want
and Montreal flips out oh yeah yeah you
see next time I love it
the unexpected guests who swam into town
global national with Donna freezin
good evening and thanks for joining us a
big development tonight in the United
States
something protestors and cities across
the country have been demanding for more
than a week in Minneapolis near the spot
where George Floyd died they cheered and
held up four fingers one for each
officer who has now been charged three
former Minneapolis officers - who pinned
him down by kneeling on his back and a
third who watched are now charged with
aiding and abetting murder they'd
already been fired and the former
officer who kneeled on Floyd's neck for
almost nine minutes while he pleaded
with them saying I can't breathe has had
the murder charge against him elevated
as trying this case will not be an easy
thing winning a conviction will be hard
and we are going to be working very hard
and relying on each other and our
investigative partners and the community
to support that endeavor
George Floyd mattered he was loved his
family was important his life had value
and we will seek justice for him and for
you
Floyd's family calls it a bittersweet
moment his son and other family members
visited the makeshift memorial to Floyd
in Minneapolis they've pleaded for the
protests to be peaceful what feels like
a defining moment in America is still
evolving people are still taking to the
streets curfews in place last night did
not deter tens of thousands of people
the question now is that all four
officers are charged will the mood
change former President Barack Obama
held a virtual Town Hall today here's
part of what he said about the protests
they're the result of a long history of
slavery Jim Crow and redlining and
institutionalized racism that too often
had been the plague this original sin of
our society
the new charges in Minneapolis are a big
step and in Washington today there was
another one the American defense
secretary says he does not support
President Trump's plan to use the
insurrection act to mobilize troops
Jackson prosecco is near the White House
again tonight as the Sun rose on another
tense morning police and federal agents
lined streets near the White House
preparing for another uncertain day of
protest Tuesday brought the largest most
peaceful demonstrations to date
thousands United in the memory of George
Floyd defying curfew gathering in spite
of the presence of security forces
deployed on the president's orders why
is he spending money on that type of
resources instead of taking care of what
we're asking him to he's not listening
nationwide 30,000 members of the
National Guard have been called up the
show of force in Washington involves an
unprecedented federal security operation
what's so highly unusual about this
situation is that these officers are not
wearing name tags or even badges it's
hard to identify what agency they even
work for and there's dissent in the
ranks the Secretary of Defense is
pushing back against president Trump's
heavy-handed threats to deploy the
military to other cities still gripped
by violence and looting the option to
use active duty forces in a
law-enforcement role should only be used
as a matter of last resort and only in
the most urgent and dire of situations
we are not in one of those situations
now I do not support invoking the
insurrection act overnight protests
turned ugly in Portland and Charlotte in
New York thousands were trapped on the
Manhattan Bridge after defying curfew
whether the protests across the u.s.
will come to a peaceful end still seems
to be anyone's guess and as this
peaceful protest builds outside the
White House tonight ahead of an 11:00
p.m. curfew there's a back and forth
over the US troops that were ordered to
the Washington area to potentially move
into the city earlier today we had heard
that they are being set back to their
home bases without ever being deployed
tonight defense secretary Mark espera
has reversed
decision they will remain in the region
on standby in case they're needed Donna
Jackson Prosecco in Washington Thanks
thousands of people marched through the
heart of London today showing their
solidarity they marched from Hyde Park
to Parliament Square chanting black
lives matter demanding justice for
George Floyd but also saying the UK is
not immune to racism and inequality you
keep killing us that's why we're angry
how would you feel if I killed your
brother that's how we feel how would you
feel then I killed your sister and you
never got justice what would you want to
do the deaths are terrible but this is
something that has been going on for
years this is something that's been
going on for my whole life this is
something that's been going for my
parents whole life hundreds of people
are gathering in Calgary to show
solidarity for victims of police
brutality and racism their demonstrators
are now marching through downtown
they'll hold a candlelight vigil at
Calgary City Hall later tonight the
arrest of a man in Kelowna BC on
Saturday that was caught on camera has
sparked an internal review in the video
to RCMP officers are seen on either side
of a man they've apprehended a third
officer runs in and punches the man and
ahead a number of times P RCMP says the
video does not show the full incident
particularly what happened leading up to
this moment it began with a report of a
suspicious vehicle and an alleged
impaired driver in a parking lot in
colonna's downtown core I recognize that
the tactics seen in the video are
shocking to many people when the third
officer arrived he observed that the man
was still resisting arrest in order to
gain control of the situation he was
struck several times and then taken to
the ground and handcuffed the RCMP says
it's conducting a thorough internal
review that will determine the duty
status of that third officer the search
and recovery of that missing Canadian
military helicopter and the
of the forces members on board is now
over the cyclone helicopter went down on
April 29th off the coast of Greece
killing all six Canadian service members
on board it was involved in a photo
shoot and was returning to land on HMCS
Fredericton when it went down witnesses
from the ship were able to help pinpoint
the location of the wreckage 3000 meters
under the water the military says no
portion of the main cabin was left
intact pieces of the helicopter were
found in clusters over a large debris
field some human remains were also
recovered while we were able to recover
remains of some of our fallen it is
important to note that we have not yet
identified these remains and I cannot
tell you whether we have found everyone
the remains will be returned to Canada
this weekend for forensic identification
family will be notified of the findings
first and then the public investigators
are still piecing together what went
wrong hundreds of soldiers are deployed
here at home working in long-term care
homes and thousands of others are
waiting because of the pandemic they've
been told to stay home and stay healthy
now after months the Canadian Armed
Forces says it needs to get them moving
or they risk losing some of their
essential skills
Mercedes Stevenson explains kovat 19
ground the Canadian military machine to
a halt for all but the most vital of
National Defense and overseas operations
troops ordered out of the field and off
of the rifle ranges all to stop the
invisible enemy of the novel coronavirus
from spreading within the military and
taking out the troops but after months
of only patrolling as far as their
backyards concerns about losing
operational readiness and becoming
combat ineffective are driving the
military back to work an internal
military memo obtained by global news
documents the concerns saying it's time
to come back to work despite the threat
of the pandemic because the military's
capacity has been progressively eroded
by the cancellation of Canadian Armed
Forces training and force generation
activities and that the forces need to
get back on track in order to prevent
the excessive erosion of Canadian Armed
Forces readiness
a senior military official told global
news the military is planning a slow
phased approach to getting back in the
saddle the first activities to resume
will be recruiting individual training
and battle school courses to teach
trades and skills troops will be
required to be two metres apart at all
times and if that's not possible to wear
personal protective equipment Canadian
military aircraft will be use to fly
troops in where possible and as
personnel return to bases they'll have
to self isolate for two weeks with no
contact with civilians to make sure they
don't have kovat 19 defense analyst
David Perry says the military has to
reactivate because of the nature of
their jobs there's simply too many
things that the military does that you
can't do from your home office or your
kitchen training and things like
firearms training pretty difficult to do
in your living room there's all kinds of
aspects of the way that the military
works is an organization that requires
you to be in an actual facility donna
june 1st has always been the deadline
that the military knew they had to come
back because after that they risked
compromising their ability to be able to
defend the country or operate overseas
one of their first priorities will be
making sure that those who are about to
ship out have completed their training
Mercedes what about the soldiers working
in the long-term care homes in Quebec
and Ontario overwhelmed by koban 19 do
we know how many have tested positive we
know that 41 overall have tested
positive but here's an important fact
with that number they've only tested
those who are symptomatic so we don't
know the total numbers but here's a bit
of the breakdown from numbers we do have
from the Department of National Defense
in Quebec 1,000 Canadian soldiers are
working in long-term care homes 26 of
them have been diagnosed that gives you
an infection rate of 2.6% in Ontario the
numbers are much higher in terms of
percentage well there are only 150
troops in the homes 15 have been
diagnosed with kovat 19 and that is a
10% infection rate the good news here
Donna is that most of those soldiers
have recovered all right Mercedes
Stevenson in Ottawa thank you those
long-term care homes have been the
epicenter of kovat 19 outbreaks in
Canada this week we're looking at why
some are failing
and how conditions can be improved
tonight Ross Lauren examines possible
future models for this country's 2100
long-term care facilities and the role
the federal government might play as
attention turns to preparing for a
possible second wave of covered 19
there's a new demand for the federal
government
it comes from long term care home
operators in Ontario ensuring their
supplies of personal protective
equipment focusing on rapid testing and
prioritizing long-term care tested turn
around a group that speaks for operators
says there are roughly 76,000 seniors in
Ontario long-term care homes for 79
thousand available beds with another
36,000 on the wait list and demand
forecast to double over the next 13
years the operators are calling on the
federal government to help create
another 147 thousand beds others call
for different federal action placing
long-term care under the Canada Health
Act like hospitals are a move that could
force provinces and territories to share
more information on the condition of
their homes and not simply just say just
give us more money and let us do our own
thing
uh-uh no sorry we saw what happens when
we do that now we're gonna play a
different game it's a game called
accountability it's called a game called
standards those standards have been
elusive and long-term care where the
ratio of nurses to residents often
depends on how understaffed a home is at
any given time even the concept of a
minimum standard of care is a revealing
term to those who studied it who would
go get your brakes fixed
and say are these minimum standards to
get my brakes fixed I mean you're gonna
say you know it's this thing at the
highest level of safety and quality that
I'm looking for so even that terminology
I always found interesting Shirley
Sharkey agrees with labor unions who
demand residents receive more attention
for hours of care per day on average
depending on individual needs some
standards are increasing like Quebec
offering higher salaries to recruit
10,000 long term care workers federal
officials say they're committed what we
have learned has been happening cannot
continue we have to make it
better and we will there are no
specifics on how only a promise to
transform long-term care with the
cooperation of provinces and territories
who are ultimately in charge of
delivering health care Ross Lord Global
News Halifax it was off now it's on
again
coming up why the World Health
Organization has resumed trials of the
drug hydroxychloroquine
a beautiful moment for some recovering
kovat 19 patients in Barcelona Spain
they were wheeled out of the hospital to
the seaside it's part of a program to
humanize intensive care units Tuesday
was the second day in a row no deaths
were reported from kovat 19 in Spain for
the first time in Canada a team of
Toronto researchers is preparing to
conduct large-scale tests looking for
people with kovat 19 antibodies the test
kits are being mailed to thousands of
Canadians starting this week the results
could shed light on a range of
unanswered questions including how many
Canadians have been infected and how
long their immunity to the virus might
last Geoff simple explains I've had flus
before but this one was unique Brenda
Rifa Scheid is a former nurse at this
Saskatchewan hospital she had her flu
shot last winter but back in February
she and several family members got sick
I had night sweats I was coffee and I
was short of breath identical symptoms -
what kovat has left wondering whether it
was indeed kovat 19 and the answer is
now within reach we hope to get out a
few thousand kits this week itself this
Toronto doctor and his team are
preparing a special delivery so the kit
comes in a package like this 10,000 of
these testing kits to be mailed to
randomly selected Canadians to check for
kovat 19 antibodies you can do this by
giving a few drops of blood at home this
instructional video shows how a quick
finger prick and five drops of blood
onto this test paper which is then
mailed back to the lab samples
containing kovat 19 antibodies reveal a
past infection we'll be able to get
really a profile of the virus in in
Canada how many people infected what
ages and whether they experienced any
symptoms
that'll give us a feel for how many
people were asymptomatic or maybe just
had really mild symptoms some countries
such as the US have been offering these
antibody tests for months already but
Canada has taken its time a lot of time
are getting emergency use authorization
without undergoing the full rigor dr.
Vandy call a Singham says the market has
been flooded with more than 200
different tests many producing
questionable results an unreliable test
is worse than no test result at all her
lab is carefully evaluating the
different tests two of which have now
been approved by Health Canada to be
used in the study the results are
expected by early August and researchers
then plan to test the same group again
later on to determine if the antibodies
last or if kovat 19 can infect again
Donna Jeff sample in Toronto thanks the
World Health Organization is resuming
its clinical trial of hydroxychloroquine
as a potential treatment for kovin 19 it
was suspended last week to conduct a
safety review the w-h-o says that review
indicates no reason to discontinue the
trial the drug is approved for use in
treating arthritis and malaria there's
hope it might be useful as a treatment
for Kovan 19 the US president says he
took it himself
despite potential dangerous side effects
and no proof it's effective also today a
study published in the New England
Journal of Medicine revealed
hydroxychloroquine is not effective in
preventing kovat 19 in people exposed to
the virus and that it is no better than
a placebo
still ahead Canada's largest telecom
companies shut huawei out of their 5g
networks
[Music]
while ways plan to install its
technology in Canada's 5g network is in
doubt all three of Canada's largest
telecom companies are turning their
backs on the Chinese telecoms company
Telus revealed its opting for Ericsson
based in Sweden plus the Finnish company
Nokia it did that
shortly after BCE the parent company of
Bell revealed it intends to go with
Ericsson technology for its 5g system
rogers has already teamed up with
Ericsson to roll out its 5g network it's
a major snub to Huawei the world's
biggest supplier of telecoms equipment
the company is facing scrutiny over
security concerns linked to its close
relationship with the Chinese government
for months the federal government has
been reviewing whether to ban Huawei
from installing Canada's 5g technology a
decision is long overdue
next the rare visitor stuck in the
spotlight in Montreal
this next story is something you don't
see every day
a humpback whale has made it all the way
up the st. Lawrence River to Montreal as
the furthest two humpback has ever known
to have traveled up the river there is
concern about its health but the mammal
is a huge attraction for whale watchers
as Mike Armstrong explains what this
crowd has come to see seems impossible
the thing is I didn't believe it I saw
it on Facebook first I'm like that's a
fake post for sure they just put up
pictures they call whale in Montreal no
it's not a hoax
there is a humpback whale in Montreal's
old port popping out of the water every
25 to 45 seconds I find it is turned
into quite an attraction the best thing
I have seen since a Cove in nineteen
started here now why does Montreal have
this strange visitor a nine and a half
metre long humpback in the shadow of
downtown we don't know if it's male or
female but young males in particular
experts say can be foolishly adventurous
it appears to be two or three years old
and could have been following prey
looking for a mate or a new feeding
ground it could also just be lost
it could be that the whale is
disoriented it's hard to know but it
could be there for a while from its
first spottings a week ago the whale has
travelled hundreds of kilometres up
River against the current it's now at a
dead end
it can't go further up the st. Lawrence
from this spot all it has in front of it
or Rapids on one side and the locks of
the st. Lawrence Seaway on the other the
question is how do you coax a whale to
turn around there have been cases in
other countries where they've tried
scaring them with the sounds of
predators orcas it never really worked
well sometimes it's worked for a day
then the whale came back well over the
last few days the whale hasn't looked
like it's had too many concerns it's
being very active at times foods not a
problem humpbacks can eat fish and can
fast for weeks at a time the hope is it
just gets bored turns around and heads
back out to the ocean I thought it was
photoshopped honestly when I first
thought
whoa my carps turn global news Montreal
and that is global national for this
Wednesday I'm Donna Friesen tonight's
your Canada is the Esplanade reel
footbridge in Winnipeg named after Louie
Riel we'd love to see your Canada please
email it to us and thanks for watching
hope to see you here again tomorrow take
care of yourselves bye bye
[Music]
[Applause]
you